et nous recevons à présent sur ce
plateau notre journaliste sportif est
mickaël mille euros pour sa chronique
sport du jeu dit bonsoir à michael la
sueur froide ravi de retrouver pour
cette chronique est là je dis merci est
ce que vous allez bien je pense que oui
parce que du coup l'on rapproche je sais
que vous êtes tout excité tout content
effectivement floral je ne peux rien
vous cacher tout le monde en parle le
championnat d'europe de football débute
ce vendredi 10 juin avec le match france
roumanie au stade de france c'est
d'ailleurs le thème de ma chronique
aujourd'hui forum surprise mickaël ne
s'y attendait pas on s'y attendait part
effectivement deux équipes étrangères en
pour qu'en base les yvelines pour cette
édition 2016 l'irlande est un versailles
et la russie et à croissy-sur-seine
aujourd'hui les irlandais se sont
entraînés au stade mont boron de
versailles devant plus de mille
supporters déchaînés les enfants des
écoles avoisinantes ont pu assister à un
mini match entre l'équipe des
remplaçants les titulaires l'irlande
magna a pris dans les yvelines
on écoute un supporter alors comme on
disait à quand on disait ça fait du bien
de voir une autre équipe jouer que que
l'équipe de france ça serait que suis
habitué plus à aller voir les joueurs de
l'équipe de france jouer donc là de voir
l'équipe d'irlande
ça fait plaisir vraiment ça fait plaisir
plus en plus bonne ambiance avec les
enfants le public ans c'était génial les
supporters avaient l'air contient
michael ça fait plaisir à voir
et j'aurai les rangs des irlandais est
également conquis l'on trouvait la
pelouse de 24 mm normes uefa et les
installations au parfaite en écoute le
défenseur irlandais stéphane world un
bel endroit pour s'entraîner on ya fait
une bonne session et on pourra donner le
meilleur en garde ont ils vraiment une
chance pour l'euro face à nos bleus mais
non on va voir en face à nos bleus
peut-être pas mais en tout cas dans ce
groupe là on ne sait pas on regarde le
groupe de l'équipe tout de suite ils
affronteront la belgique de eden hazard
l'italie et la suède de zlatan
ibrahimovic
l'ancien à parisien autant vous dire que
la tâche s'annonce compliquée pour les
irlandais vous ne trouvez pas florane le
groupe paraît compliqué donc la porte
entre la belgique et l'italie je pense
qu'à mon avis ça doit vraiment compliqué
pour s en sortir mais bon les joueurs et
les supporters y croient quand même oui
je pense parce qu'il ya une forte chance
que le troisième le troisième équipe
avance donc eh oui je crois qu'il aura
l'opportunité de prendre quatre points
non pas du tout pas du tout on est déjà
on est on est déjà joué trois fois
contre le souhait des zlatan l'a
parfaitement maîtrisée n'utilisait
problème en d2
nous allons tenter de donner le meilleur
de nous mêmes et je pense que les autres
équipes vont tout donner pour tenter
d'accéder au prochain tour de la
compétition
mais toutes les équipes dans notre
groupe toutes les équipes de la
compétition vont tenter d'accomplir leur
objectif la victoire fait l'exact sont
optimistes comme on dit l'espoir fait
vivre
voilà il faut floral en tout cas comme
l'a rappelé aux supporters les meilleurs
troisièmes seront qualifiés pour en
dehors des phases de poule i pour
accéder aux huitièmes de finale donc
rien n'est perdu même si la belgique je
pense que la belgique dans ce groupe
peut quand même leur crée des soucis en
tout cas on leur souhaite comme ça on
rencontrera ni les belges en italie et
pour nous c'est mieux on passe
maintenant à l'équipe de la russie siens
moins médiatique l'équipe de la russie
s'est entraîné au stade omnisport de
croissy sur seine devant plus d'une
centaine de supporters venus notamment
du club de football local les joueurs
ont réalisé une petite opposition et on
est également signé des autographes
on écoute les supporters des joueurs
mais des joueurs très forts qui faisait
beaucoup de passes
et qui marquait bien les buts ça me fait
plaisir que nationale viennent
s'entraîner dans ma ville et sur le
terrain où je joue pour acheter ce
manhwa ouais ça me fait plaisir de voir
des pros dans ma vie loi les russes sont
loin d'être favoris dans leur groupe
l'amicale modèle favori mais le groupe
funk l'asie pour sauver le groupe est
quand même plus équilibré que pour le
groupe de l'irlande les russes
affronteront l'angleterre comme on peut
le voir de wayne rooney au vélodrome de
marseille le match aura clairement
compliqué ce premier match au vélodrome
mais ça sera plus jouable contre le pays
de galles de gareth bale et la slovaquie
du napolitain marek hamsik je sais que
vous êtes fan de ce joueur
particulièrement je pense qu'ils peuvent
être une des surprises de l'euro avec
leur gardien et hakim vf
regardez le en images regardez comment
il s'entraîne florane une petite
galipettes et la meilleure frappe la
balle voilà il se fend d'un des
meilleurs gardiens actuellement va nous
donner des belles 17 euros le sentiment
merci à beaucoup michael